mit 74 jahren ist donald trump ist
sozusagen ein medizinisches wunder wenn
der korona tatsächlich so schnell so gut
überstanden hat die therapie die
verarbeitung ist der multi mund aber
also verschiedene bausteine der therapie
scheint ja offensichtlich doch geholfen
zu haben was ja ein positives signal ist
aber nichtsdestotrotz ist er präsident
trump immer noch aus der medizinischen
sicht und das sagen seine ärzte ja
eigentlich und schulen auch nicht aus
der risikozone heraus das ist ein
politisches manöver medizinisch würd ich
sagen stelle sagen äußerste
zurückhaltung weiterhin quantifizierung
weiterhin sollte der präsident sich
außerordentlich schonen und seinem
körper zeit geben den virus endgültig zu
bekämpfen er ist noch nicht aus der
gefahrenzone heraus definitiv nicht
therapie diese gerade angesprochen haben
natürlich wollen das jetzt
wahrscheinlich ganz viele menschen die
selber erkrankt sind aber eines der
medikamente dass donald trump bekommen
ist ja noch in der experimentellen phase
eigentlich also gibt es irgendwelche
hoffnungen dass wir normalbürger
sozusagen demnächst genau so therapiert
werden können wieder no trump im moment
ist es so dass es eine substanz system
in klinischen versuchen getestet wird
phase eins zwei und drei studien laufen
parallel
die substanz soll auch nach
großbritannien für überstellt werden
2000 dieser dosierungen
das ist aber auch eine britische multi
center studie die dann auch mit dieser
diesem monoklonalen antikörper cocktails
feucht werden sollen im moment aus dem
wissenschaftler sieht würde ich sagen
lassen sie uns bitte abwarten was die
enten und den ergebnisse zeigen werden
erstens zweitens die firma nie eine
andere amerikanischen grosskonzern hat
ebenfalls einen monoklonalen antikörper
in der klinischen testung und man kann
schon davon ausgeben
dass diese substanzen relativ rasch
zugelassen werden so dass wir sicherlich
in 1 23 monaten mit einer zu lassen
solche haben ob dann die substanzen im
europäischen raum zur verfügung stehen
werden das sei mal dahin gestellt und
über den preis da wird noch gar nicht
drüber geredet ganz genaue betrachter
der szenen gestern haben für sich
erkannt dass donald trump trotzdem
anscheinend noch immer schwierigkeiten
hatte luft zu bekommen wir wollen uns
einen video nochmal anschauen das jetzt
auch durch die sozialen kanäle geht denn
donald trump hat ja versucht immer
wieder zu zeigen
ihm geht's gut den daumen hoch gestreckt
die faust aber dieser kleine clip dem
wir uns jetzt einmal anschauen zeigt
vielleicht dass genau das gegenteil wir
sehen hier eröffnet schon sehr tief ein
in ihren augen ist das tatsächlich schon
atemnot die mit corona zusammenhängt
oder sozusagen fast mehr dass er jetzt
im moment genießt wieder da zu sein vor
seinen fans also aus der distanz heraus
wäre das total spekulativ davon ab nur
zu reden ist ja sehr stramm hilfe von
hubschraubern aus marschiert also ich
würde sagen im moment kann ich das aus
der ferne überhaupt nicht beurteilen das
sollen die ärzte vor ort bitte machen
ich würde nur wirklich dringend davon
abraten dass ein patient nach dieser
doch kritischen phase so zurück in die
öffentlichkeit kehrt und das
allerwichtigste ist wirklich dass er
seine mitarbeiter schützen und nicht
denke mal die ganzen signale die hier
ausgesendet werden unverwundbarkeit
das ist nicht so schlimm dass gruner
wäre es dass aus medizinischer sicht
muss ganz ehrlich sagen das erschüttert
mich zutiefst und wirft wirklich kein
gutes bild auf das verständnis von
dieser weltweiten pandemie die uns im
augenblick wirklich alle und viele viele
menschen in die knie zwingt der schutz
der mitarbeiter das letzte horch mit
ihnen noch einmal eingehen will denn
donald trump hat sofort seine maske
wieder ausgezogen und die frage die sich
jetzt viele menschen auf der welt
stellen und vor allem auch seine
demokratischen gegner ist denn donald
trump jetzt wirklich nicht mehr
anstecken er spricht selber davon dass
er jetzt immun ist die maske brauchte
anscheinend nicht mehr stimmt das
überhaupt
also wir befinden uns ja theoretisch
56 nach nachwuchskoch zwei infektionen
müssen davon ausgehen dass er immer noch
theoretisch und praktisch wie iris
ausscheider ist das ausmaß dieser virus
ausscheidung ist nicht zu beziffern
aus sicherheitsgründen musste und sollte
erweitern quantifiziert werden und auch
seine mitarbeiter und er müssen sich
gegenseitig schützen dass meine feste
überzeugung so würden wir mit jedem
patienten umgehen und warum soll das für
den amerikanischen präsidenten nicht
gelten mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schaue ich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren